the US and Canada and in fact the West  generally has ignored the situation in  East Timor in part it hasn't ignored it  totally so for example the United States  England and other countries have been  very pleased to send arms to Indonesia  it's profitable and it helps them  consummate the massacre they've been  interested in this sense but the actual  ongoing slaughter itself has been of no  concern to the West except that they  want it to be consummated efficiently  and effectively and they would like to  see each team were integrated into  Indonesia one of the major slaughters of  the modern period in fact relative to  size probably made her major slaughter  since the Second World War